وجنبا الى جنب ما دراسته الاحتياجات اعلنت
واشنطن انها ستقدم حزمه مساعده جديده
لاوكرانيه بقيمه الفجر تتجاوز خمسه مليار
دولار يبدو ان الولايات المتحده مصممه على
دعم اوكرانيا وسط تقدم الروسي لدرجه انها
ارسل الذخيره كانت مخزنه في اسرائيل
لتستخدمها اوكرانيا في الحرب والعهده هنا
على نيويورك تايمز الامر واقرا به مسؤول
اسرائيلي لرويتر تقريبا نحو 300,000 قضيتك
مدفعيه من عياري 155 مليم وهذا الدعم
الغربي الكبير والامريكي تحديدا
الاوكرانيا اللقاء عليه الكريم لان اليوم
ستدخلون بشكل مباشر في الحرب ودباباتكم
اللام توقفنا عن تحقيق اهدافنا
على العموم اجانب الدعم العسكري ياتي مع
دعم واشنطن الاستخباراتيه لكيابها فواشنطن
بوست اشارت اليوم الى ان مدير سي اي ايه
سافر الى اوكرانيا سرا من الاسبوع الماضي
والتقى الرئيس الاوكرانيه اذا كان الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا ساعدها ويساعدها لمقاومه
الهجمات الروسيه فهو جاءك طريقه لاختبار
الاسلحه الغربيه في ساحه المعركه ولا كان
نجوما لمعه واخرى اف
مدافع والحاضر مثلا كبيره وفقيله تعملوا
ضمن معدات المدفعيه الاخرى في مجموعه تسمى
البطاريه يجب على المدافع اطلاق النار
والانطلاق بسرعه من خلال ربطها بعربه الجر
والانتقال الى موقع جديد لتجنب رد العدو
على اطلاق النار
امريكي اكد لسي ان ان انا حاضر اصبح من
الماضي سلاح اخر طائره الدعم الجوي
القريبه الفعاله بفضل طيرانها ببطء وعلى
ارتفاعات المنخفضه اوكرانيا اثبت ان معركه
طائرات الدعم الجوي القريب خاسره اذا تم
استخدامها في خط المواجهه ضد عدونا لديه
دفعه جويه حديقه
على الجانب الروسي سنبدا من النجاح
مسيراته لانسيت ثلاثه الانتحاريه توفر
لموسكو وميزه هامه القدره على ايجاده وضرب
احداث متحركه مثل صواريخ هاي مارس من مدن
بعيد وعلى عكس الصاروخ التقليدي او الموجه
او الموجه يمكن للمسيره الانتحاريات عن
فطيره عشوائيا بحثا عن اهداف الدهون تحدي
موقعها بشكلنا مسبق